(lighthearted music)
We're gonna turn our attention
to maternity care too,
and this is a discussion we're gonna have related to kind
of medical issues and intrapartum issues,
and we'll start with this question.
A 32-year-old pregnant woman at 34 weeks comes in
with a blood pressure, systolic blood pressure,
greater than 140, and the diastolic is over 90.
On examination, she's developed edema
in her face and hands along with mild epigastric pain.
Laboratory tests reveal elevated liver enzymes
and thrombocytopenia.
Urinalysis demonstrates a significant presence of protein.
Considering her symptoms and finding,
what specific renal manifestation
would be most indicative of her condition,
distinguishing it from gestational hypertension?
It would be the reduced glomerular filtration rate.
(audience laughing)
So it's a learning opportunity
'cause proteinuria is no longer needed
as a factor in gestational hypertension.
So let's look at the definitions
of hypertensive disorders of pregnancy.
By definition, we define hypertension
as greater than 140 over 90 on two occasions at least.
So four hours apart, or greater than 160 over 110,
either of those.
Now, once we do that,
we gotta figure out what the diagnosis is.
Is it preeclampsia or is it eclampsia?
Is it chronic hypertension?
Is it chronic hypertension with superimposed preeclampsia,
or is it gestational hypertension?
Now, let's take a look at the diagnosis
of preeclampsia and eclampsia.
Key take home.
This does not occur before 20 weeks.
You do not have to have proteinuria as long
as you have one or more of the severe features.
Now, we don't collect 24-hour urines anymore.
It's too cumbersome.
We use a protein to creatinine ratio.
If it's greater than .3, we have significant proteinuria,
or on a dipstick or some other qualitative measure,
I have two plus or more.
Now, what are those severe features
where I don't need proteinuria,
but I still have preeclampsia?
Well, if I got significantly elevated blood pressure,
as we said, greater than 160 over 110, platelet count low,
impaired liver function,
progressive renal insufficiency, pulmonary edema,
new onset headache, which is unresponsive to medication
and visual disturbances, any of those
and the blood pressure, doesn't matter
if I have proteinuria.
Now, patients who have had preeclampsia,
four-times increased risk of hypertension
and a two-times increased risk of ischemic heart disease,
stroke and venous thromboembolic events.
Now, here are the risk factors for preeclampsia.
There are pregnancy associated factors.
There are paternal specific factors,
including, I, myself, was the offspring
of a preeclamptic pregnancy and lastly,
there are maternal specific factors.
Keeping in mind any medical condition increases your risk
for this, and that's where they're gonna go on the exam.
They're gonna tell you they've got diabetes
or renal disease or a thrombophilia.
Now, remember, eclampsia is where I have a seizure
on top of the preeclampsia.
Chronic hypertension is the third issue.
This is where I have a gestational blood pressure elevation,
but it's before the 20th week.
Chronic hypertension is the most common cause
of intrauterine growth restriction.
Now, a quarter of these women are going
to develop the fourth issue,
in terms of hypertensive disorder,
where I develop preeclampsia on top
of my chronic hypertension.
So normally, when you're pregnant,
whether you're hypertensive or not hypertensive,
as you move into the second trimester,
you see a fall in the blood pressure.
Well, if you have chronic hypertension, you're gonna see
that fall and then all of a sudden, it starts going up.
Is it going up
because their chronic hypertension's getting worse,
or they're developing superimposed preeclampsia?
That's where the lab can come in to help
because if you have chronic hypertension,
your uric acid will be normal.
You won't have hemoconcentration.
You won't have abnormal liver function tests.
You shouldn't have an elevated protein and creatinine ratio
or 24-hour total urine protein,
if that's the way you're looking at it, okay?
So you never want to just increase
the blood pressure medication in a chronic hypertensive
as it's going up because you could be masking
their preeclampsia developing.
How do we manage this?
Here's April of 2022-ACOG.
We used to use 160 over 110 as the threshold
for lowering blood pressure in pregnant women.
More recent data suggests we should use 140 over 90.
What this chap study did not show,
which is the chap stands for chronic hypertension
in pregnancy, is where do we need to get to?
Where do we need to get to?
However, we no longer use the threshold
of greater than 160 over 110 to treat.
We now use the threshold of over 140 over 90.
Some of some of you're thinking, well,
why would it we have ever used a different threshold?
Because remember, we manage chronic hypertension
in a non-pregnant patient to minimize long-term sequelae.
Day-to-day, it doesn't make any difference.
However, here we recently have learned
that perhaps this could have an impact on management
of the pregnancy, even though it's nine months, okay?
Blood pressure medications at the start of the pregnancy,
they can be maintained on them
with the exception of ACEs or ARBs.
If we look at the American College of Cardiology
and the American Heart Association way back in 2014,
they recommend either methyldopa, labetalol or nifedipine.
Most people use labetalol now.
So I had a patient come in not too long ago.
She's trying to get pregnant, trying to get pregnant,
and she had recently seen her obstetrician gynecologist,
I'm not doing her prenatal care,
and they kept her on her ACE inhibitor.
I'm like, "Are you trying to get pregnant?"
She said, "Yeah, I came off of my birth control."
The obstetrician gynecologist said,
"Okay, we're gonna stop it."
I'm like, "Did they know you're on an ACE?"
She said, "Yeah, they looked at all my medications."
I'm like, "We're gonna stop that today,"
and we put her on labetalol.
Okay, after giving birth, you may need to continue these.
Now, we now have a way of preventing preeclampsia.
So we start everybody at about 12 weeks who has a history
of preeclampsia, or they're at high risk
on low-dose aspirin, and you continue that through delivery.
Continue that through delivery.
Here's what the USPSTF says in terms of high risk,
and therefore, you need aspirin.
History of preeclampsia, multi-fetal gestation,
chronic hypertension, diabetes, renal disease
or an autoimmune disease, okay?
12 weeks, and we continue it through the end of pregnancy.
Now, gestational hypertension,
which accounts for the last two types.
I've got blood pressure rise after 20 weeks.
So I'm worried about preeclampsia,
but I never develop a severe feature,
and I never get proteinuria.
We can further delineate this after they deliver at 12 weeks
because if it goes to normal,
they had transient hypertension of pregnancy.
If it doesn't, they've got chronic hypertension.
The timing of delivery here.
Gestational hypertension or preeclampsia
without severe features, you want to get 'em
to 37 weeks and deliver 'em.
Women with chronic hypertension,
no additional maternal or fetal complications.
IE, something that says you need earlier delivery.
If they've not been prescribed hypertensive medications
because they have been persistently less than 140
over 90, you deliver by 38 weeks.
If they're on medication, you deliver by 37 weeks.
Here is just a summary of that
in terms of our recommendation.
So you can put that with your study materials.
Now, how do we manage eclampsia
and the potential for eclampsia?
Well, we give 'em anticonvulsive therapy.
Magnesium sulfate is used both
for prevention and for treatment.
Now, it's only recommended
for prevention if you have preeclampsia
with severe features.
Now, you can use it with mild to moderate,
but it's only recommended for severe features.
It reduces the risk of subsequent seizures
in women who already have eclampsia.
That antidote for the toxicity is calcium gluconate.
You treat their blood pressure.
Here, a vaginal delivery is preferred
because many of these women will develop DIC,
and that's the last patient you wanna be operating on.
Now, sometimes you can have an eclamptic pregnancy.
I remember one very specifically eclamptic.
Everything settled down.
Induced her, got her to fully dilate,
and then, of course, she couldn't push the baby out.
Had to do a forcep delivery,
and I remember thinking,
"I better not put a stitch too deep here"
'cause she had this enormous tear up into the sulcus,
and I'm like, "I better not put a stitch in too deep here
'cause I'll be in the bladder."
She'd probably been better off with the cesarean section.
Okay, she's step right over here.
She's still with that furrowed brow.
She's like, "Oh, my gosh." (laughs)
Okay, acute hypertension in preeclampsia.
Definitely if it's greater than 160 over 110 intrapartum,
you want to treat that,
and we wanna get it down to below 140 over 90.
Beta blockers are what we normally reach for.
Look at this, though.
Calcium antagonist giving a dose of nifedipine PO.
Actually works faster than labetalol IV, hmm?
Okay, postpartum.
I'm gonna reevaluate them at 7 to 10 days
and then reevaluate them at 12 weeks
to determine do I need to continue blood pressure medication
for persistently elevated blood pressure?
30-year-old woman known
to have preexisting type two diabetes presents
for her regular antenatal checkup at 32 weeks gestation.
Her glucose control has been variable
despite rigorous management.
The ultrasound reveals a fetus
with an abdominal circumference
measuring greater than 95th percentile
for gestational age.
The mother's hemoglobin A1C levels
have been consistently elevated throughout her pregnancy.
Considering her medical history
and the fetal ultrasound findings,
which perinatal complication is most likely attributed
to the fetal exposure to maternal hyperglycemia
in this scenario?
Is it RDS, neural tube defect,
intrauterine growth restriction or macrosomia?
Good, there we go.
Macrosomia, which is by definition greater than 4,500 grams.
Keeping in mind, do you know what the best estimate
or how you determine the best estimate
of fetal weight at term?
Any ideas?
Ultrasound.
Ultrasound is the least accurate.
It'll be off by as much as 20%.
Leopold's, I heard.
That's the second most accurate.
That's where I feel the mother's abdomen.
The most accurate way hands down,
has been shown over and over and every study ever published.
(audience chattering)
You ask the mother how much do you think the baby weighs?
(audience laughing)
That is the most accurate predictor
of the fetal weight at term.
Amazing, isn't it?
Okay, why do we worry about diabetes?
From a maternal standpoint,
hypertensive disorder, cesarean,
because of macrosomia, there's an increased risk
of intrauterine fetal demise,
if there's persistent hyperglycemia,
particularly fasting.
From a fetal standpoint,
excessive fetal growth and ounce for ounce,
if you have an infant of a diabetic mother,
you will see a broader bisacromial
or shoulder diameter in the infant
of the diabetic mother than you do
in the infant of a non-diabetic mother.
So 4,000 grams, the baby is architecturally
looking different in an infant
of a diabetic mother than the infant
of a non-diabetic mother,
and then there's neonatal morbidity, hypoglycemia,
hypocalcemia, hyperbilirubinemia and polycythemia.
Now, we initially manage this
with nutrition and physical activity.
What's the threshold at which we have to start treatment?
We don't really know.
When we do start treatment, insulin is first line.
Glyburide, not recommended.
"Well, Dr. Weismiller, I am not going on insulin,
or I don't think I can take this,"
then metformin is the second-line drug.
We don't know exactly when to start.
However, what we're going for are fastings less than 95
and two-hour postprandial less than 120.
If on more than three occasions you exceed this,
you should start insulin therapy.
In our practice, we really focus on the fasting blood sugar
because we know that the persistent fasting hyperglycemia
leads to most of the poor outcomes.
So in my patients,
if the fasting is less than 95 every single day,
and she's occasionally bumping around at 130
or 140 postprandial, I don't start insulin.
Okay, now, what about the delivery?
Controlled, and I'm an A1.
That is, by definition,
diet and physical activity controlled.
I delivered them at, not before, 39 weeks
and not after 40 and six, seven weeks.
Well controlled, but they're on medication,
I wanna deliver in the 39th week.
Poorly controlled, typically we're delivering
at 37 to 38 weeks.
In a mother who has diabetes,
if the estimated fetal weight is greater than 4,500 grams,
you can consider a primary section.
Rarely is that done.
For a non-diabetic mother, you can consider this
if the estimated fetal weight is greater than 5,000 grams.
Long-term considerations.
Up to 35% of women who have gestational diabetes
will develop diabetes within 5 to 10 years of parturition,
and the infant there is an increased risk for obesity,
glucose intolerance and diabetes in late adolescence.
We wanna reclassify mom preferably
about four weeks postpartum,
using either a fasting plasma glucose
or a two-hour glucose tolerance test.
If that is normal, the recommendation is
to reevaluate that annually per the USPSTF
or every three years per the ADA.
26-year-old G2P1 presents at 30 weeks, severe itching.
She has excoriations from scratching in various areas.
She says that she had the same problem
during the last pregnancy.
You review her medical records and see she had a diagnosis
of intrahepatic cholestasis of pregnancy.
Elevation of which of the following
is the most characteristic of this disorder?
Serum GGT, serum bile acids, serum unconjugated bilirubin
or a prothrombin time.
Which of those is most characteristic?
Okay, serum bile acids.
Some of you're thinking now how would I order that?
You just go into your order set
and look for serum bile acids.
It's right there. Promise you.
Promise you.
Okay, now if we think about this,
it's the most common pregnancy related liver disorder,
although it is not common.
We don't know really what causes this.
We just know it tends to recur.
Historically, they will itch at night,
then they'll itch continually, and there's no rash.
About a half of them will develop jaundice.
Rarely do you see this early in pregnancy.
More than 20% of women are known
to be infected with hepatitis C will develop this.
Therefore, you should screen
for hep C in patients who have this.
Liver biopsy is rarely going to be needed.
What you're looking for is a serum bile acid
greater than three times the upper limits of normal,
and in terms of treatment, you only have
to worry about one drug, ursodeoxycholic acid
because this is the only drug that benefits the infant.
Mom, you will see a decreased pruritus
and a decrease in the bile acids,
but you improve the fetal outcome for the baby
because in the baby, you've got a serious issue here
in terms of fetal compromise.
There's an increased risk of cesarean.
There's an increased risk of meconium.
There's an increased risk of intrauterine fetal demise.
Not a small issue,
but for mom it is an impaired quality of life,
and it will resolve as soon as she delivers.
Okay, bleeding late in the pregnancy.
The two things we need to remind ourselves
of are placenta previa and placental abruption.
Now, here's the question.
A 28-year-old woman at 34 weeks arrives
at the maternity unit.
She's got significant vaginal bleeding.
No associated pain or discomfort.
The bleeding is moderate on exam,
and the fetal heart rate is stable.
Which of the following conditions is most likely
to result in painless vaginal bleeding in late pregnancy?
Cervical polyp, abruption, previa or cervicitis?
Okay, and it is placenta previa, placenta previa.
Let's talk about that.
So now we have a placenta,
which is not optimally positioned
and covering part or all of the cervix.
Now, keeping in mind that
as they have painless vaginal bleeding,
each successive episode becomes more.
Now, the etiology, typically we don't find one.
However, here are the risks.
Anything that has damaged the myo or endometrium.
As Dr. Fernhaber pointed out,
cocaine is not good for many things,
advanced maternal age and tobacco.
Malpresentation is the result, not the cause of this,
and it tends to recur.
Now, before 24 weeks, we just have expected management.
Now, I say here, you will need
to confirm movement of the placenta.
The placenta does not have feet.
(audience laughing)
However, think about the uterus as a balloon,
and you put a mark on a balloon.
As you blow up the balloon, there's relative migration
of the superior and inferior pole.
If it is not cleared by 24 weeks, it's unlikely,
and that patient's most likely going to need a cesarean.
Placental abruption, what's the key here?
High rates of recurrence.
It is a clinical diagnosis.
Abdominal pain and bleeding and no other cause,
you don't care what the ultrasound shows.
They have an abruption until proven otherwise.
Etiology, again, cocaine,
hypertensive disorders, tobacco.
With an abruption, you're assessing fetal viability.
If there's been demise, IE,
you've got more than a 50% detachment.
You deliver the fetus,
and you're gonna prepare to transfuse mom.
If there's a live fetus and a rigid uterus,
again, greater than 50% of detachment,
very high rates of demise.
Live fetus in a soft uterus,
you can probably proceed with induction, okay?
Now, remember, the third stage of labor
between delivery of the baby
and the delivery of the placenta,
that is a massive abruption.
That's how the placenta is delivered.
Okay, here's our antepartum hemorrhage,
previa versus abruption in your study materials.
Preterm labor.
I'm more than 24 weeks, and I'm less than 37 weeks.
I'm contracting, and I got cervical change.
Now, here are the risk factors.
It's happened before.
Any question on the exam where they start
with G2P1 with a history of, it's gonna happen again.
I've had residents call me at three in the morning,
"Dr. Weismiller, 28-weeker here, yada, yada,"
and then they go into what she had for dinner,
(audience laughing)
where she lives.
Is she safe?
And I'm thinking, is she contracting
and is there a history of preterm labor?
Because if she is, I'm on my way now.
We can learn about everything else later.
It's important.
Don't get me wrong.
Sometimes they forget
to tell me whether she's term or preterm
because if she's term, great,
let's go ahead and talk about this,
but if she's preterm, I'm on my way
'cause they're at increased risk.
Lots of babies in there are short cervical length,
when you're evaluating the cervix
between 18 and 25 weeks.
They give you somebody at 30 weeks
with a short cervical length, that doesn't mean anything.
Interpregnancy interval is short, tobacco and any infection.
Okay, here's the symptomatic management.
Activity restriction preterm labor, no benefit.
Hydration, no benefit.
Tocolytic agents, the first line agent
is a beta adrenergic agonist.
It doesn't help you with the exception
of prolonging the pregnancy long enough
to get the thing on board that does help you,
which is corticosteroids.
You get one dose between 24
and 34 weeks if you're at increased risk.
Antibiotics in terms of prolonging the pregnancy
are only helpful if you've got ruptured membranes.
If the membranes are intact, and she's preterm,
and you don't know what her GBS status is,
then, of course, she gets GBS prophylaxis
'cause she's in a high risk group,
but that doesn't prolong the pregnancy.
Magnesium sulfate reduces the risk and severity of CP,
if they're gonna deliver potentially before 32 weeks.
In terms of prevention, you know we've had a lot on this.
For a while, we gave 17-alpha-hydroxyprogesterone caprate.
That is not recommended for primary prevention any longer.
If you're going to look at a single pregnancy
with no prior preterm birth, the only thing you can do is
to look at cervical length between 18 and 22 weeks.
If there is a prior preterm birth,
and there's a short cervical length,
these patients may benefit from micronized progesterone
and a cerclage placement.
I don't think that's gonna be on the exam.
Okay, here's our next question.
26-year-old gravida three para two,
mild chronic hypertension.
Uncomplicated pregnancy has just delivered
a vigorous female by spontaneous vaginal delivery.
She's noted to have heavy vaginal bleeding,
and a bimanual exam reveals a soft,
poorly contracted uterus.
Her temp is 37, blood pressure 168 over 97,
pulse 105, oxygen saturation 95% on room air.
Which one of the following uterotonic agents
is contraindicated in the management
of this patient's postpartum hemorrhage?
Oxytocin, carboprost, misoprostol or methylergonovine.
Okay, good, methylergonovine.
That's gonna drive the blood pressure up even higher.
Now, postpartum hemorrhage,
we have gone through at least 10 definitions
of this since I started practice.
It is now a cumulative blood loss of more than a liter
or blood loss accompanied by signs
and symptoms of hypovolemia.
Now, remember, these are otherwise healthy individuals.
So they will be able to tolerate a lot.
Early, first 24 hours after delivery,
late, after 24 hours, but before six weeks.
Now, there are four pieces you need
to remember here in terms of why this happens:
tone, tissue, trauma and thrombin.
Now, tone accounts for 90% of them.
Why would I have poor uterine tone or uterine acne?
Well, I got lots of babies in there.
I got a big one.
She's been on oxytocin for four days.
This, she's a G11P10.
(audience laughing)
They've got a infection.
Retain placental fragments,
including pathologic placentation,
accreta, increta, percreta.
Trauma, you cut in a episiotomy thinking
that was gonna help you,
and it's just bleeding until they deliver,
and now you've lost 1,500 CCs of blood
or a uterine inversion.
People always say, "Dr, Weismiller,
how am I gonna know if it's an inversion?"
Listen, if something's hanging out,
and you don't know what it is, put it back in, fast
(audience laughing)
because it's gonna contract down,
and you won't get it back in.
I had one patient when I was in fellowship many years ago.
She ruptured, not once, but twice.
Luckily, she decided after the second rupture.
Survived, both, baby survived both,
that probably she shouldn't have any more babies.
So we did a tubal ligation.
She probably came back pregnant again, though.
Okay, and then thrombin.
Oh, excuse me.
Thrombin, hereditary,
DIC or a severe form of preeclampsia,
HELLP, hemolysis, elevated liver enzymes, low platelets.
Now, the treatment of this, bimanual massage,
and you can see there, your fist is
in the vagina, not two fingers.
You've gotta clamp down.
Oxytocins, inspect for lacerations
and surgical intervention if it doesn't stop.
Now, here is the treatment:
oxytocin or misoprostol, methylergonovine,
carboprost or hemabate or PGE2 dinoprostone.
That's for treatment.
Can we prevent it?
Well, if the mom's non anemic going into her labor,
and she loses 900, she can tolerate it probably.
So she won't become symptomatic,
but if she's anemic, and she loses 900,
all of a sudden, she's gonna be hypovolemic.
We don't cut routine episiotomies anymore.
I can't remember the last time I cut a routine one,
and I remember being in residency where I worked with one
of my attendings who cut 'em all the time,
said, "easier to repair."
No, put the infant on the breast.
That releases oxytocin.
Some of you have heard me tell the story before.
I had a medical student's wife I was delivering one time.
She had a postpartum hemorrhage.
He went to the breast, the husband.
(audience laughing)
(David laughing)
You know, you can't make this stuff up.
Routine use of medications after delivery of the placenta.
So here are the medications for prevention
of postpartum hemorrhage:
oxytocin,
misoprostol, only when the oxytocin is not available.
There's one other way to prevent it called active management
of the third stage.
Now, what is that?
Well, you have to know what expected management is.
That's where we await separation of the placenta.
We leave the cord uncut.
We spontaneous delivery of the placenta.
We're singing kumbaya,
and the oxytocin and breast after placental separation.
Now, when I tell you what active management
of the third stage is, you're gonna be like,
"That really prevents postpartum hemorrhage."
That shouldn't, but it does.
Here's what it does.
At delivery of the shoulder,
I turn to the birth assistant and say, "Open the oxytocin."
The cord is clamped and cut early.
By definition, two minutes.
The baby is passed a mom,
and with controlled cord traction
with that next contraction,
when the oxytocin sit in the uterus,
I have controlled pull on the cord,
and I deliver the placenta.
That decreases your risk of postpartum hemorrhage.
Here are postpartum hemorrhage recommendations
that we have looked at.
Lastly, everybody's favorite thing, postdates pregnancy.
This doesn't happen anymore.
We used to let people go to 42 weeks to 43 weeks.
No.
Now, we have cervical ripening agents.
Some of you remember the Bishop score.
Dr. Bishop invented this way back in 1963
at Pennsylvania Hospital, and he was like,
"You know, if you can get the cervix
to a Bishop score of eight,
you have the same outcome
as if they went into spontaneous labor."
So we have cervical ripening agents.
You don't need to know the Bishop score in terms of that.
It's just that if we can ripen the cervix,
we have the same outcome
as if they went into spontaneous labor.
Now, you look though at eight,
three to four centimeters dilated.
You faced cons.
Okay, so you can understand why, if we can get there,
and we can push it there now with cervical ripening.
Okay, macrosomia, as we said, greater than 4,500 grams.
We know that beyond this, the morbidity increases.
What you wanna encourage is not to get here.
Regular exercise and control of maternal hyperglycemia.
Suspected macrosomia is not a contraindication
to labor after cesarean, and in terms of induction,
unfavorable cervix, ripen,
then induce labor with, typically,
oxytocin, and delivery, of course,
needs to be affected more quickly
if there's any evidence for compromise,
and with that, thanks.
It was easy.
I appreciate your attention.
(audience clapping)
(lighthearted music)